hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
machine for pigs okay we seem to have
entered into a church which in horror
games is always gonna be good
twin candles been to the will of the
central saint casting their light to the
corners of the chapel father Jeremiah I
thought could be trusted with the secret
but he is like all of the others so the
old priest has gone to the holding pens
with its flock
she says he will enter into our world
with them a shepherd indeed if you say
so definitely a lot of references to
pigs in livestock okay you guys are go
hey there my another pig mask okay okay
I've got the volume turned way up in my
headphones so I'm really catching a lot
of the ambiance here let's see what if
we got here hang on wait a minute there
was something over here
hello is that a screamer is that just an
intercom your faith shackles your vision
professor it is an iron coffin that
keeps you from grasping the future we
require a new deity while a steam and
the wheel of magnetism and progress the
old God is nothing more than a named hog
spitting back awful at mankind okay yeah
right another reference to pigs very
very very good sir
very good sir wool hello
Wow nice very Phantom of the Opera ask I
like it a lot
so we got some sort of a church here
oh is this is where the screenshot is
with the Piggy's that I saw in part of
the trailer hello piggies how are you
I heard that can't tell me I didn't I
heard that a fricken heard that can't
escape me
who's in there okay so this seems to be
some sort of device here some sort of
lever I hear something
besides the just the organs here okay
seems to be a machine someone holding a
heart of a pig way up high and then
another machine over there not sure what
it all means but wait a minute
aha aha Oh what was that
what did I do some kind of mechanism a
secret an infernal one no doubt the
missing candlestick is clearly the
answer but why this I can't fathom why
hide secret machines in a place of
prayer and where the faithful while the
drag marks about the altar as if someone
was pulled away someone pulled away as
they were praying I'm guessing that's
what these are or a pig let away for the
slaughter either way I need to find
another candlestick can't I just take
one from
okay I would have I would have I would
have preferred that you keep playing
it's much creepier when you're not
playing
oh nice statues here there candlestick
that is a pig uh-huh
that is a pig well that's got multiple
boobs
it is a pig why why is that a pig Sam
that is also a pig oh it's like into the
music stop I actually took a look around
and suddenly things got way more creepy
okay there's another set of doors over
here okay
oh wait this is just the place it led
over here see God something aha I think
I found a candlestick good great good
what the hell when you play this guys
and I highly recommend that you do
definitely check out the UH turn just
turn up the volume play the game the
ambience in this game is just ha here we
go
turn that in ok what did that do oh did
that little lock a thing so I can ah
hello we got a nice glow from a fire
here see infernal machines the engines
fire the flames are stoked I hear steam
in the walls I hear screaming the walls
but my children beckon me on and I
cannot fail ok so my heart falters that
was the other line I kind of skipped
that one kerja
oh my whoa what the hell what kind of
machinery are you building here freaking
weirdo it appears I have no choice yes I
descended may God have mercy upon my
soul if this is my bedlam and I am to be
cast as Matthew's then I will wear that
mantle for the sake of my boys in face
whatever horrors lie beneath the altar
what horrors do lie down here hey wait a
minute
I wanna hi I have some protests about
going into the darkness oh come on oh oh
oh
a look at chest hey that was
interactable inanimate user I hear
something what is it was it a fly okay
nevermind okay so we got some holding
pens here what kind of egg do you have
kid I don't think it's a normal egg and
I think that you should stop haunting me
from beyond the Google okay no how about
no no no no why don't you do that
you son of a [ __ ] you better oh what
exhumation is is what rotten fruit what
be stitching of parts I doubt I will
ever be found yet I leave you this
scrawled in the malodorous half-light
whilst my torments are shuffled below my
fellow prisoners keen and squeal in the
gloom and where I wait for the knocking
upon my cage that signifies it is
finally my turn to make that dark
journey into the interior okay so I'm
guessing the congregation kind of
medical okay
okay no no no good sir I don't think I
will
hmmmm
who's talking who's
okay Oh No
shut up hey ho who's in there
I don't see anyone I saw something
I saw a skittery who's a skittery
skittery who's skittering it was a
moving there's a lot of cages down here
a little too quiet little too quiet
little Turk why little too quiet oh why
am i coming down here why in the world
did my boys back at me down this dark
corridor I feel my soul being lost in
the light okay stop it huh
huh power today oh my god Oh Bart out
ho-ho attack and tax lien thingy it is
actually the thingy
boom oh no oh my god oh my god Oh
Oh
and so do the stoking pulling cogwheels
now sneezed into his handkerchief when
the dust got into his eyes I have begun
to change more rapidly he surmised oh oh
oh I didn't even see him
oh I start with the outline hail he was
Sam hi hey literally Olli
trihard mode engaged
oh my god sorry I panicked a bit too
much there I was I was awesome husk oh
my god that was so amazing I didn't even
see him I didn't even know what was
happening at that point I couldn't even
tell that as lot pigs those love pigs oh
my god
that was so cool it's so bad oh good I'm
outside can I run away now can I go home
once again I wonder why the door that
leads right to the dungeon underneath
the church where their friggin cages
full of people still full of people why
I can get out immediately once again in
an amnesia game I'm not used to being
outside even in custom stories you don't
often go always and the sparks of the
embers in the wheels it's too bony it's
too damn moaning okay it's too bony I'm
sorry oh wait man disco meat processing
factory since uh 1828 okay well ain't
that something I can move the windows
may love the music in this game but
right now I'm kind of have more pressing
concerns than just the music okay I
don't think there's anything else over
here time to go inside hello I'd like to
purchase a large order of meat a giant
sausage if you will man professor these
so-called men of vision they would
shackle the masses to a wheel and turn
it to their backs break all that opiate
velour a profit these fools who lack
even these priests these officials this
government Erick pixels all not solution
my tin man how to break a cycle you
can't simply remove the
a better world for these unfortunates in
the work houses in the orphanages that
belief in heaven is surely the only
sucker one can find we do not need to
wait we can ring for paradise now we can
speed the passion with only a small
sacrifice we can hold the apocalypse
with just a small sacrifice weaken okay
so apparently the machineries is I had
to kick on that's great you know what it
was amazing that I only realized just
now about that monster showing up before
there was no music there was no
announcement music there was no intro
scream you know whenever a monster came
into the original amnesia there was
always the hole or the grunt you know
there was none of that
whose none is that there's none of that
none of that I don't know if that made
it worse or better I don't know somehow
oh why why why do you do this to me dame
i try to love you look how's it fan i
thought that was some nevermind i try to
love you game and yet you would turn all
my affection with horridness and i love
you even more for that ding-dong anybody
gonna ring me I knew it
they were the wretches who populate this
compound the way you seek is under the
distance when you meet the saboteur you
will understand everything
ah I don't think I will but I think I
saw someone drive by hey can you take me
to safety because this is kind of awful
what I'm going through here maybe okay
so I gotta go down beneath the Pistons
into this horrifying alright I'll go
back up that's great
all right nope ah not going down there
ever ever ever I can't even pick up a
box alright time to go back to my old
time-tested method of anti monster nests
come on come at me bro
so ready for you I'm still ready I'm not
ready what does that sound what's going
on it's coming from all around me I
can't pinpoint it
okay or is not stopping I'm just gonna
carry on now pissing control room how
excellent
oh how incredibly excellent man that
wasn't nightmarish in horrible I love
that oh it's great
okay so stop are all your furnace is
fueled I don't think so
I think I saw that these furnaces over
here what I needed
whoo all right you can you can hush show
pretty little face can't seem to open
that one but I see coal on the ground
let's see I don't know what these dials
mean maybe I got to put more fuel in
this fire maybe huh no what is that
noise I swear to gosh I hear a noise
justice constant screeching in my head
it's enough to drive a man insane I
don't know probably
okay got three pieces in there three the
match number
Baboosh yeah all right I got it I think
maybe I don't know maybe it won't last
this one is not on fire is it oh yeah it
is okay that one's on fire that one's on
fire that's two Pistons I don't know
about the third one
uh-oh how are you about up
get in there dry more coal yeah in there
close it up fire down okay
did that do it okay that did it alright
can I do this now no no still missing
something
oh I see okay I'm hip to your I'm hip to
your lingo there's got to be another ha
number six over here is what I need okay
it's got anyone over here that's not on
line looks like number six okay
you know the giant pieces of coal in I
need another piece of coal or at least I
think I do
I'll see I have no idea give me that
gimme gimme gimme gimme okay alright
seems like we've gotten a gentle
reprieve from never mind I was wrong I
was about to say we got a gentle
reprieve from the horrific atmosphere of
the game but apparently not I know what
those notes say those don't say that
there's I was not there before you
mother humper you son of a [ __ ] you
piggy bastard
where am I even gonna go I must be the
owner to all this because only I would
know how to do this crap
oh boy what did I do
what did I do
okay that doesn't huh oh the big a
legend piggy piggy piggy
okay it's a piggy still there the piggy
to go away piggy piggy oh I gotta go
down let me go down ah come on
okay okay I'm down going down to the
piggies to the piggy piggy piggies it is
dark and loud ah come on who's doing
that who's ooh The Saboteur they keep
talking about is it the
something-or-other
oh crap
it's training me I know this game is
playing mind game
hi guys Oh anything anything into
thinking oh that was actually you're
thinking oh is it after me or what I
don't know I don't know I don't know
this game I don't know what to do and it
does a thing who's actually a thingy
there
what's our fire north oh my life okay
was there or was there not oh okay that
wasn't it
okay I'm going no need to tell me three
times cuz you already told me before
Asif Vika oh no my god dammit Oh
goddammit get up get up get up get up
get up get up oh crap oh crap oh my god
it is there oh my god what is it oh it's
so ugly
oh it's so ugly oh my got it there's it
a closet to hide end oh no you don't see
me piggy little piggy no no little Pete
you're home this will be the first time
I've actually seen it oh my god oh my
god oh my god is big there's a big oh my
god it's the biggie
I still get barely sad oh no no no no no
no
no no no no no no no no no Oh No
why is my what what is my light doing
it's signaling the bastard
Oh what's with your arm buddy Oh No
Oh No what if I go oh oh my life
flickers while I'm here I'm going for it
I'm going for it oh oh oh oh where do I
go what do I do down here
yep okay soothing alright well I made it
down into the coal good for me I'm so
happy for me what have I done what have
I done the crate arrived this morning
and I had to deliver directly to the
workshop the body is remarkably
preserved although there is a subtle yet
nauseating stench of dab and rot it is
humanoid in shape but has suffered a
severe skeletal deformity remnants of
leather straps in case the torso which
if tis deformed with evidence of
substantial muscle mass and displacement
it is difficult to ascertain whether
that's unfortunate is the recipient of
some barbarous surgery or was born
deformed an attempt to force his gnarled
body into some semblance of humanity was
made what he is I cannot tell but I
smell the orb upon him and suspect my
great uncle's presence in his curious
condition so it can be done we can
reshape the body into a tool accelerate
the process of mr. Darwin's evolution
but here my great uncle and I part
company
he chose men as the subjects of his
experiments but men are difficult to
control in Rawdon with sentimentality
snow we require a new creature for our
chattels loyal clever strong easily
sated like a pig wow that actually kind
of reveals a lot of the story here on
how it connects to the Oldham amnesia in
OneNote that was the grunt they were
talking about with the leather straps
the moose man add the metal plating on
him so that's different so anyway now
it's really cool this is getting awesome
guys this is getting amazing I love this
so much it's so good so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
I found a secret key I'm out of here
oh darling
in there's bad news
I got a double check make sure the
husband
early walk abide that guy's being
fertilized